une réouverture attendue après 81 jours
d'arrêt suite à l'épidémie de kovy 19
les visiteurs sont de retour au château
de versailles depuis ce samedi 6 juin
dès ce premier week-end de plusieurs
milliers d'impatients déambuler dans
l'ancienne demeure du roi soleil on
piaffait d'impatience pour revenir
évidemment aujourd'hui on a fait le tour
du grand canal comme on fait quasiment
toutes les semaines
très très près mais on arrive
m'attendais ouais bah ouverture donc ça
cesse et c'est merveilleux on attendait
ça avec impatience
on vient assez régulièrement sur le sur
le château et on voulait venir justement
faire des photos et c'est extraordinaire
d'aller là je rêvais d'aller ici mais
aujourd'hui je suis là pour répondre à
la crise sanitaire des mesures ont été
prises les masques sont obligatoires à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
la jauge de visiteurs est réduite par 5
avec réservation obligatoire
aucun audioguides n'est distribué les
parcours ont quant à eux été raccourci
et repensé il faut s'habituer à vivre
avec des formats de visites plus petits
mais aussi peut-être plus d'une certaine
manière plus agréable pour ceux qui vont
faire les visites
je pense que cette jauge nous n'allons
pas la garder éternellement mais pour
l'instant effectivement on ouvre les
portes de versailles d'une autre façon
puisque on emprunte un vaste couloir qui
permet de de se promener à travers les
appartements royaux
les événements vont également reprendre
au château de versailles les grandes
eaux nocturnes l'un des rendez vous
phares de l'été seront organisés chaque
samedi de fin juin jusqu'au 19 septembre